Сільське господарство дуже дорого обходиться довкіллю.
Але є можливість зробити його більш екологічним, причому цей метод не новий, його практикували ще тисячі років тому.
І пов'язаний він з таким буденним, але вкрай важливим аспектом як дерева.
Промислове сільське господарство руйнує навколишнє середовище:
26% усіх глобальних викидів парникових газів спричинені сільським господарством.
Монокультури зернових виводять з ґрунту поживні речовини.
Крім того, сільське господарство займає величезні земельні площі.
То яким чином могли б допомогти у цьому поодинокі дерева?
Цей напрям зветься агролісництво. Система, яка поєднує в собі традиційне землеробство, розведення тварин та висаджування різних типів дерев.
І, як стверджують, це скорочує викиди, вимагає менше добрив і навіть більш естетично! Вау... це як виграти екологічну лотерею.
Щоб з'ясувати, чи справді це так, ми навідуємося до Йохена Гартманна.
Його родина господарює тут 19 поколінь.
Проте він один із перших, хто почав висаджувати дерева серед злакових полів.
Дерева на полях - на уроках землеробства цьому, мабуть, не вчать?
До цього треба трохи звикнути - і мені теж. Часто з'являється думка: "Навіщо це робити?" Адже нас вчили так: чим більше поле, тим краще.
А ми робимо його меншим. Це наперекір традиції, але це круто!
Йохен Гартманн вирішив висадити на перехрестях тополі. Вони прості в догляді і займають близько 10% його 200 гектарів.
Цим тополям вже 5 років.
Зараз вони близько 10 метрів заввишки. Це означає, що у них всередині зберігається багато CO2.
Можливість поглинати CO2 і тим самим сповільнювати зміну клімату - головний аргумент на користь агролісництва.
І ці дерева прекрасно виконують свою функцію у поєднанні із… курчатами. Їх тут 500 штук.
Як ви бачите, щойно вийшли з вантажівки і почали їсти. Їх вигодовують не так, як за традиційних методів землеробства.
Вони їдять те, що знаходять. І це дійсно сприятливий для довкілля метод, оскільки викиди CO2, пов'язані з вирощуванням курей,
спричинені значною мірою їхніми кормами. А коли вони годуються ось так, не потрібно спеціально для них вирощувати корм в інших місцях.
Інакше це б робилося у трьох окремих місцях: розведення курей, вирощування сільськогосподарських культур та посадка дерев.
А тут це - три в одному, що скорочує використання в землі.
Листя дерев також дає затінок, де птахи можуть коротко перепочити і сховатися від хижаків.
Після того, як листя опаде, курчата втоптують його у землю, що дає ґрунту поживні речовини.
Щоправда, вплив курей на довкілля все одно залишається. Частину кормів для них все ще вирощують як монокультури.
Проте бодай частину CO2, який продукується у ході ланцюга постачання, компенсують дерева на тій же землі, на якій вирощуються і кури.
Якщо 9 відсотків аграрних земель перетворити на агролісові системи, це могло б нейтралізувати від 2 до 43 відсотків загальних викидів CO2
у сільському господарстві Європи, стверджує одне з досліджень.
Такий широкий діапазон пов'язаний з тим, що агролісові системи можуть варіюватися
від маленьких смуг кущів, які практично не поглинають CO2, до великих посадок дерев.
Якщо поглянути на наші наявні системи алей та посівів, то вони поглинають від 1 до 1,5 тонн вуглекислого газу на гектар.
А якщо співставити це з усіма вуглеродними викидами в Європі, тоді агролісові системи
могли б поглинути до 10 відсотків усіх викидів CO2, що створюються сільським господарством.
Це все ще дуже багато CO2. Але є одна негативна обставина.
Якщо посаджені дерева використовуватимуть як дрова, а у майбутньому буде саме так, то близько 70 відсотків вуглекислого газу знову піде в атмосферу.
Це якось суперечить ідеї поглинання вуглецю.
Ці дерева зрубають, коли вони виростуть. Але поряд з поглинанням CO2 НАД ЗЕМЛЕЮ дерева мають інші позитивні ефекти ПІД ЗЕМЛЕЮ.
Вони можуть поліпшувати якість ґрунтів та, ймовірно, скорочувати необхідність у добривах.
Ви думаєте, сучасне сільське господарство знаходить рішення проблем, які воно ж саме створило? Якби ж!
Насправді агролісництво існувало ще у давнину.
І про це є наочні свідчення. Ці середньовічні картини показують, як свиней ведуть у ліс, щоб похарчувати різними видами горіхів.
Індійські сади, які комбінували різні ґрунтові культури з високими деревами, існували навіть 7000 років до нашої ери.
Але у першій половині 20 століття такі системи значною мірою зникли. Їх визнали неефективними.
Розкидані по полю дерева заважають тракторам та іншим великим сільськогосподарським машинам.
Оскільки експеримент з тополями і курками так добре спрацював, Йохен вирішив поширити систему на всі свої поля.
Ці дерева висадили кілька місяців тому. Тепер треба прибирати бур'яни, інакше дерева не виростуть. У перший рік агролісова смуга є більш трудомісткою.
Звичайно, у нас менше ріллі, але пізніше ми матимемо ще деревину.
Сільське господарство вже нині потерпає від вітру і спеки.
Якщо так триватиме ще три тижні, тут поступово все висохне.
А завдяки деревам буде вітрозахист і вони затримуватимуть вологу в ґрунті.
На іншому полі захист від вітрової ерозії стає ще більш очевидним.
Дерева блокують вітер, що дме по полю, не даючи продути багатий поживними речовинами ґрунт.
Врожайність на краю поля частково втрачається, тому що дерева також хочуть своєї частки води, але посередині врожайність знову врівноважується.
До того ж, ці дерева сприяють біорізноманіттю серед комах, черв'яків та грибів.
Через вітер вони завжди ховаються. Повисюхові мухи теж корисні. Дивись, он кілька. А он там - жук-гнойовик.
Але у смузі тополь зараз не так багато комах, чи не так?
Терпіння! Ми ж посадили їх лише торік. Ми ще висадимо багаторічну квітучу смугу праворуч і ліворуч. Як буферну зону.
І також тому, що на перших трьох метрах, біля тополь, погано збирати врожай. Отож посадимо там дикі квіти, і це подвоїть ефект.
Ну тоді почнімо.
Цим ми також створюємо кращий життєвий простір для диких бджіл.
Отож сенс не лише в тому, щоб мати між двома монокультурами кілька тополь.
Якщо ви тримаєте дерева у смузі, це зовсім не проблема для великих машин.
Вони не заважають і насправді приносять нам лише переваги з огляду на вітрову ерозію.
І мені вже цікаво подивитися, який це матиме вигляд у найближчі кілька років.
Можна легко розрахувати цю систему навіть для великих ферм. Як тут, в Іспанії чи Кенії.
Але такі підходи також практикують на невеликих фермах, у країнах, де сільське господарство більш фрагментоване. Як тут, в Індії.
Гаразд, але якщо агролісомеліорація має стільки переваг, чому б нам просто не перетворити кожну ферму на агролісгосп?
Є місця, де дерева садити не слід. Ґрунт недостатньо товстий. Дерева там не виживуть.
Тож перед тим, як почати агролісомеліорацію, слід уважно перевірити, можливо це чи ні.
Ґрунт багатих водою рисових полів або гірських регіонів може стати проблемою для дерев.
Крім того, початкові витрати на створення системи агролісового господарства є досить високими і в Німеччині не субсидуються. Поки що.
Агролісове господарство - чудова система з великим потенціалом.
Поєднання тварин, рослин та дерев також робить сільське господарство більш стійким до екстремальних погодних умов -
що буде дуже корисним у майбутньому.
Звісно, саме по собі це не вирішує всіх сучасних аграрних проблем.
Але, порівняно зі звичайним сільським господарством, це добрий початок для створення більш екологічного сільського господарства.